اذا كان العمود الفقري لنظام مهددا فما هي
حال اطرافه كما يفعل المرشد في طهران ان
يردده السيد في بيروت حزب الله يستنسخ
روايه الانكار والتخوين بحدثيرها والنقل
دون اجتهاد او تفكير كما يقال وهنا لازم
تغيير الخطاب نصر الله بدا بمهاجمه
المحتاجين في ايران تقييم جاء في وصفه
جاهزه للتعميم حيث يتعرض المحور الايراني
للاهتزاز وبين لبنان وايران تشابهن كبير
هموم معيشيه تبدا عند ارتفاع خط الفقر ولا
تنتهي عنده هبوط العمله الوطنيه وحلما
عنوانه الهجره تشابه يسهل مهمه امين عام
حزب الله بالقاء اللوم على المؤامرات
الخارجيه تماما كما طهران واذا كانت
انتفاضه المراه والشباب الايراني هي فتنه
براي سلطات طيران من باب المجامله روحوا
ابناء البلد في لبنان قطعونا الامريكيا
براي حسن نصر الله حقوا المعلم على
التلميذ لا ينتهي الا بعد موته ونصر الله
نجيب يعمل من اجل تحقيقه طموحاتنا ومصلحه
معلمه الاكبر ويطمع بالحفاظ على منصبه في
مشروع الحزام الذهبي الايراني في المنطقه
ما جرى في اكتوبر 2019 في لبنان يجري في
نوفمبر 2022 في ايران وهو كابوس يكشف
وتملم الشعوب وتخلص نفود الانظمه
الاستبداديه واذرعها
ديكتاتور
[موسيقى]
كتاني اولاد